you know I I have very um I have very
complex feelings right now in regards to
you know daredevil just meaning that I'm
so proud of the last season that we had
and I'm so thrilled with the response
that it had and it just it just feels
you know a little strange for us to not
be do you know continuing with it you
know based on the on the response we had
from the last season so in many ways I'm
so happy that we got to end on such a
high note and who knows if there's any
you know any more dead level to come in
the future I'm sure there will be in
some capacity but for right now like
kind of happy and sad after daredevil
where do you consider playing like
another superhero like the green arrow
or moon nights or someone else you know
what I right now I couldn't imagine that
at all it's impossible for me to imagine
that maybe in a few years you know and I
know it's been done as in people have
played multiple superheroes or whatever
for right now I not for anything else
just out of respect for the character I
feel like I just want to let some time
pass you know you know and also vaguely
hoping that the DD will have another
life at some point so
[Applause]
hi I found that sorry I'm so sorry I
found out the other day there's this
petition these guys are wearing this
thing save their devil there's a thing
you can sign it sign it now sign it yeah
hi my name is Abigail I'm sorry I'm so
sorry
I'll be right with you I gave my
two-year-old daughter an email address
so that she could cite it she's sorry
I was kidding I see that we have a guest
on stage hello everybody I I don't mean
to interrupt but I was too excited by
the coincidence that you some of you may
already know this but I wanted to come
and sort of announce even though it's
already been nuts it's such a
coincidence that Charlie and I are both
in the same building because only a
couple of days ago it was announced that
Charlie is going to join Zoe Ashton in
betrayal in London it's so cool because
I've been signing autographs and a bunch
of people have they found out Tom was
doing betrayal
display they they ordered online to play
they had already had tickets to come
here and then like yesterday they found
out that I was going to be in as well so
when they've showed up to sign this
thing they'd like couldn't this like
couldn't believe this has happened it's
so cool and Tom and I haven't seen each
other for about four years and and then
we found out we're gonna do is play
together in London and then I knew we
were coming here this weekend so very
exciting see some of you there I'm sure
and here's what I here's what I'll say
which not many people don't mean much to
you now but we haven't played squash for
years
that's nice that hanging me yes ladies
gentlemen Tom Hiddleston I'll get out of
the way is there an arc a story that
you'd like to see brought in as far as
if there were a season four
I
[Music]
yeah it it's tricky because I I it's
tricky to answer this in fact I have to
be really careful here just because I
happen to know details of what was
planned and so in the off chance that
there would be at some point as you know
I wouldn't want to say too much but what
I can say which i think is vague enough
is that I would I'd be really excited to
see Benjamin Poindexter really come into
his own and really really kind of embody
bullseye and for that to see that them
face off them and him in daredevil face
off with the fur that would that's
something that I was looking forward to
immensely in the future but there's so
many great storylines man hey everybody
it's Charlie if you guys didn't know
there's a big comic-con that's happening
this weekend obviously Charlie Cox is
they're talking about daredevil stuff
MCU stuff Tom Hiddleston is they're
doing the same thing talking about
Avengers endgame Loki MCU related stuff
there's a whole bunch of news obviously
there's a bunch of cool stuff that
Charlie Cox reveals about the future of
the daredevil character as well as what
they were planning on doing for season
four then them joking around about
working together so I just broke this
town top five style for like the most
important stuff and the stuff that's
relevant to what's happening after
Avengers endgame we're still doing that
imax ticket giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite daredevil moment on the
video so number five Charlie Cox just
talks about how he feels about the end
of the series obviously he says it's
very complicated and he doesn't want to
speak out of turn or say anything that's
gonna get him in a big trouble but I
think the more important thing number
four is when the fan asks him if he
would play another superhero character
which he said says Charlie Cox is like
oh it's been done before people have
gone on to play more than one superhero
in the MCU he's specifically referencing
Chris Evans and Michael B Jordan both of
whom started out as the Human Torch in a
Fantastic Four movie then went on both
of them to more famous MCU roles is
Captain America and his kill monger in
the Black Panther movie but even though
he did say you know I would totally be
willing to do it in a couple years he
kind of wants to wait a little while
just to see if there's still more life
for his version of daredevil somewhere
else inside the MCU
so that's really
to Kevin Feige like now that basically
Marvel's getting the characters back
after a couple years cooling-off period
which is also why he says he's gonna
wait a couple years before doing more
superhero stuff because built into the
Netflix Marvel contract that they
originally wrote there's this
cooling-off period of a couple years
where Marvel can't just turn around and
put the characters wherever they want
right away they have to wait just like a
little while before they shuffle them
into the MCU or wherever else they want
to use them three he jokes about signing
the save daredevil petition that's
actually a real thing in real life true
story I signed my two-year-old daughter
up for an email account so she could
sign it sign it and then he just keeps
stopping that girl short before she can
ask her question sorry give me one more
second seriously sign that petition you
know if you guys are wondering about the
actual petition Marvel has already
announced that they do have plans for
the daredevil characters so I don't
think that the actual petition will do
anything Marvel already knows that
everybody wants more daredevil and
they're gonna give it to us it's just a
matter of that cooling-off period this
is the wait a little while before they
can actually announce what it is their
plans are but let it be known that there
are actual plans they will have more
daredevil inside the MCU
eventually to that big Tom Hiddleston
moment with him surprising Charlie Cox
on stage the thing is as Tom Hiddleston
is there for a separate panel that's
happening tomorrow so also do a video
for that if he says anything really cool
but they have a separate project they're
working on together that they were
trying to hype up that's happening in
April and March like when we're watching
Avengers end games they'll be doing
their special project it's called
betrayal it's a play they work together
before like they've been friends for a
long time but like II said that they
hadn't talked to each other in about
four years because they were so busy
doing each of their own separate
projects Charlie Cox also talks about
the comic book arc that they would have
done for daredevil season 4 had they've
gotten it like he doesn't want to give
away too many spoilers but he talks
about bullseye coming into his own
becoming comic book bullseye in them
facing off I think the comic book arc
that he's referring to is Frank Miller
bullseye something like roulette which
was daredevil 191 which is one of the
many iconic Frank Miller daredevil
stories but number one the really big
Tom Hiddleston low-key news like post
Avengers end game is that you guys have
all heard about the Loki TV series set
after the events of Avengers end game we
knew Tom Hiddleston was gonna star in it
but the scuttlebutt now is that it's
supposed to be
loke or a much younger version of loki
with Tom Hiddleston narrating and doing
voiceover in appearing during some
scenes in the series like tales of
Asgard scenario where Tom Hiddleston's
Loki is telling his story remembering
his past adventures which I think kind
of makes sense if they do it from that
perspective because that's how you do
versions of Thor Odin the other really
big Asgardian MCU characters who were
played by ælis actors like Idris Elba
Heimdall who aren't really likely to do
this Marvel limited series although
ADRA's Elba does Luthor he actually does
limited TV series so it's not super
far-fetched that you have Idris Elba
cameo on that TV show but we'll talk
more about that when we get more details
they've been talking about The Scarlet
Witch Vision TV series they've already
started hiring people to actually start
making that they haven't listed any
premiere dates for any of those big
Avengers spin-off TV series with the big
MCU characters but it sounds like it's
gonna be happening later this year when
they launch the Disney streaming service
so the minute that launches you should
be able to watch episodes of all this
stuff like I said though if Tom
Hiddleston does a really big panel
tomorrow it says anything cool about the
Avengers movies I will totally make a
video for it but the really big news is
the game of Thrones is announcing when
it's actually premiering they're
probably gonna drop a little teaser so
I'll do a breakdown video for that
tomorrow while you wait for everything
click here for Tom Hiddleston's other
big Comic Con panel where he talks about
a whole bunch of Loki and really cool
Avengers stuff and click here to rewatch
that brand new Captain Marvel trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you